today on the Matt Walsh show religious
liberty has been canceled for the
foreseeable future in case you hadn't
noticed or as one police officer
explained as he was breaking up a
drive-in worship service for Easter your
rights have been suspended but what
makes us think the government will
politely restore our rights after having
suspended them for this pandemic and is
it a good idea in general to give the
state the power to suspend our rights in
the first place so we'll talk about that
also five headlines including the New
York Times basically attempting to
exonerate Joe Biden of sexual assault
and the attempt was disastrous and
ineffective for a number of reasons
we'll talk about all of that coming up
but first just to begin with I you know
I want to say Happy Easter
of course and I hope you had a blessed
Easter I know my kids did mainly because
of the candy now of course we tell them
they know the real meaning of Easter and
they appreciate that but what comes down
to it at their age the main thing is
gonna be the candy and that was
certainly the case for them my youngest
son in particular speaking of candy is
is lucky to still be alive I think
because we put him down for a nap
yesterday afternoon Easter afternoon and
he snuck out of his room apparently like
a like a ninja he was able to sneak out
I was I was out in the main area man I
should have seen him I didn't see him
that's that's what kind of an attentive
parent I am he snuck out of his room and
grabbed his Easter basket and smuggled
it back into his room with him and then
was gorging on candy in his crib for
about 45 minutes when I thought he was
napping and the only reason I found this
out is because 45 minutes later he tried
to sneak out of his room again to get a
glass of water because he was
understandably parched from all the
candy and that was really kind of
pushing it so he pushed his luck I saw
him then so as a father you know you
Mike you might get away with it the
first time if you're a kid if you're my
kid but the second time I'll catch you
and if not the second time the third
time I'll definitely catch you anyway I
saw them coming out and he had chocolate
all over his face and he was currently
in the process of chewing another piece
of candy had a piece of candy in his
mouth that he was eating while I was
talking to him and I said what's going
on buddy eating candy and he said no I
said what's all that stuff all over your
face I don't know and I said oh come we
go check your room to see if there's
candy in your room and then he tried it
he bolted for the
or to try to stop to try to lock me out
to get there before me I had to run and
stop him and I went in and sure enough
there's candy all over his crib he's got
a whole pile of it as empty Easter egg
shells you know all over the the floor
he'd eaten probably about a pound of
candy although I should say in fairness
this is all alleged because he did
explain that he doesn't know how the
candy got in his crib and then another
point when I asked him again he said he
got there by accident he said it was on
accident
I guess he tripped and fell and candies
went all over the crib and someone into
his mouth you know it was a total
accident and then a third time when I
asked him later he got into this
elaborate story about how Darth Vader
had put the candy in his crib so I you
know who really knows what happened I've
got my theories he's got his claims you
see who knows but either way it was a
good good Easter for him okay so because
it was Easter yesterday and you know in
times past people would go to church on
Easter but it is illegal now to go to
church in most states in the Union in
most states in the United States right
now it is illegal to go to church even
on Easter and many states stepped up
their enforcement of these laws that
they have passed or these not even
really laws just policies directives
from the governor saying you can't go to
church now III about two weeks ago I
talked about this issue on this show and
I wrote a dilly wire column about it and
I said that in my opinion the forcible
closure of churches and the arrest or
fining of pastors who hold services and
people who attend those services is a
clear and direct assault on the First
Amendment and in fact if that is not a
clear direct assault in the First
Amendment I don't know what is if that
doesn't qualify then I don't know what
possibly ever could that to me seems
like the the clearest example you could
you could ever dream of of the the
government infringing on the First
Amendment land of the free also you know
we say land of the free home of the
brave and eventually when these
lockdowns are lifted and we have
sporting events again which maybe will
happen let's hope again in the future
there's going to be foot
and they're gonna sing the national
anthem and people are gonna stand up and
sing land of the free home of the brave
and we're gonna have to figure out how
to do it with a straight face and I'm
not sure how we do that at this point
because what does it even mean anymore
how can you look around at this country
right now and say we are land of the
free and home of the brave where are we
seeing that exactly it has to mean
something
and if our commitment to freedom is it
can be can be suspended or if we are
only committed to freedom up until the
point when we're afraid of something
then our commitment to freedom is not
really any different it's about on par
with the rest of the world there's
nothing special about us in that regard
so let's just admit that at least if we
are basically free most of the time
until the government has a compelling
interest in its opinion to suspend those
freedoms if that's what free for us
means then we are no different from
dozens of other countries across the
world we're no freer we're no different
we're no better when it comes to that
now we may be better than still you know
countries like North Korea but most
countries on the globe right now if you
go there you're basically free most of
the time unless people are really afraid
of something or unless the government
says it has a special interest in taking
those freedoms away so that's what it is
right now in America then we're no
different from those other countries now
at the time when I made that argument a
shocking number well at least for me as
a as a as a hopelessly optimistic and
naive sort of person as you know it was
a shocking number of self-described
Christian Christian conservatives who
stood up to valiantly defend the state's
right to close every church at gunpoint
they defended it on the basis that
people who go to church might get sick
and we can't have that and also that you
don't really need to go to church it's
not a need right it's not essential so
they're agreeing with with all these
state governments who have figured out
that they can easily get around the
First Amendment all they have to do is
just declare that churches are
non-essential it was that
apparently getting rid of the First
Amendment was as easy as a governor
standing up and saying churches are
non-essential that's all they had to do
and First Amendment exists anymore
effectively and that's what they do now
of course abortion clinics are still
essential liquor stores are still except
essential but churches are not and
they're able to close them down and what
I discovered is that many conservatives
agree yeah the churches are
non-essential closed them up it's fine
and then they turned around and said
that actually people like myself and and
others who have opposed this that we're
the problem okay we're the irresponsible
ones we're we're we're the real danger
well I wonder what the people in that
group the Christian conservatives
defending the government as it shuts
down churches and arrests people for
going to church what will they have to
say about what happened yesterday across
the country so let me just give you two
examples two examples that I'm hoping
will even wake up the people in this
group but before I do that a quick word
from policy genius you know there are
things we look back on in our own lives
and we think how did I get it so wrong
how was I so wrong about this and in
fact to be honest my copy right here
tells me to talk about things that I
have gotten really really wrong in my
life and the problem is I'm supposed to
keep this to 60 seconds and it wants me
to talk about the things I've gotten
wrong the list is far too long and
really this is a pretty this is a pretty
emotionally penetrating thing to try to
put it to it
advertisement excite you know I could
City I've gotten many things wrong in my
life many more things wrong than right
and we're always going to get things
wrong that's why that's what it is
that's just life but there are also
things we can get right on the first try
like shopping for life insurance that's
where policy genius comes and policy
genius makes finding the right life
insurance a breeze in minutes you can
compare quotes from top insurance to
find the best price you could say
fifteen fifteen hundred dollars or more
a year by using policy genius to compare
a life insurance policy that's a right
that's a right call there's no way
that's the wrong call once you apply the
policy genius team will handle all the
paperwork all the red tape for free and
policy genius doesn't just make life
insurance easy they also make it
you know they make it easy to find home
insurance and auto insurance disability
insurance whatever it is you're looking
for so even if you look back on your
past failed predictions in distress
you'll never be distressed about life
insurance with policy genius in just a
few minutes you can find your best price
and apply at policy genius com
we all get things wrong from time to
time or if you're me all the time at
least we can get life insurance right
with policy genius okay so a few things
that happen yesterday first there's this
in Mississippi a pastor by the name of
Eric Simmons tried to hold a drive-in
service so that means that everybody was
in their cars windows rolled up
attending church no plausible chance of
anything being spread really you're in
your own car very safe yet a bunch of
cops rolled up and disperse the crowd
anyway threatened fines and everything
shut it down shut down this drive-in
church service for Easter and I want you
to listen to what one of the police
officer says when explaining why why
this is happening and why they have the
right to shut down this church service
listen look at this y'all all the people
we heard through the grapevine we're
having served as a 630 and there's more
police cars at a church service yes this
is King James by a Baptist Church what
pastor Hamilton where I'm the pastor the
church at I'm a good citizen ain't
breaking no law ain't selling no drugs
I'm just preaching the Word of God and
look all the police car here I mean I've
served on starts at 6:30 this is America
private property of a church no the
government our right don't come from
Authority it comes from the Bible so the
authority does not have the right over
the constitution we come to customs
allow the first Second Amendment the US
Constitution that was given to us by our
forefathers we can't give take it away
mayor Eric Simmons can't take it away
nor the police officer it came
No okay your rights are suspended that's
what he said
so suggest the review here what we're
dealing with a bunch of cops shutting
down a drive-in church service and
informing the congregants that their
First Amendment rights have been
suspended suspended by order of the
governor if you heard that's what he
actually said which makes it even
creepier by order of the governor your
First Amendment rights have been
suspended now this is really interesting
because when I've claimed in the past
that these shutdown orders amount to a
suspension of the First Amendment I've
been told that no no no that's not
what's happening what are you any
crazier you still have your First
Amendment rights they're not suspended
well here is a police officer who is
shutting out a church service saying
your rights have been suspended
is that enough is that enough evidence I
would think that the guys in guns
arresting people for going to church is
evidence enough that your First
Amendment rights have been suspended but
but maybe when they tell us that your
First Amendment rights been suspended we
can all now admit that our First
Amendment rights have been suspended and
now the only question is are we ok with
that and if you are then here's my
question
in what sense are you a proponent of
religious liberty I mean if you want to
argue that the state can do this and
that it's fine then go ahead and argue
that but please don't turn around in the
future and say I believe in religious
liberty religious liberty tell me give
me a definition of religious liberty
that allows for the possibility of cops
threatened to arrest or find people
simply for going to church and telling
them their rights are suspended please
give me a definition of religious
liberty and free speech that
incorporates that and then tell me in
what sense is that liberty or freedom
now it gets worse over in Kentucky and
this is all happening in the South in
the Bible Belt which makes it so much
worse but in Kentucky the governor
decided that anyone who goes to church
on Easter will have their license plates
taken down and will be put in a system
and then will be placed on a mandatory
14 day house arrest for going to church
now they call it a quarantine
but that is not the right term and I'll
explain why in a second but first let's
take a look at some of the reporting
from Sarah Ladd who's a local reporter
there in Kentucky on the scene at a
church that was holding services on
Easter and cops were there to take down
the plates put it in the file and place
them all under house arrest so here are
just here's a here's a little footage of
some of the cops putting out these
notices and then here's a photo of one
of the notices my eyes aren't great so
it's hard for me to read this but you
could say it says this vehicles presence
and this is these are notices that were
put on all the cars there this vehicles
presence at this location indicates that
its occupants are present at a mass
gathering prohibited by orders of the
governor at the end the cabinet for
Health and Family Services as a result
this vehicles occupants and anyone they
come into contact with are at risk of
contracting kovin 19 a respiratory
illness that can be severe and lead to
death particularly for older adults and
those with underlying health heart lung
kidney and immunity issues where people
congregate unnecessarily or fail to
follow adequate social distancing
practices they are spreading kovat 19
creating scenes of an emergency and then
later it's kind of down at the bottom
it's obscured by the wiper but it says
associate so it's it says this is a self
quarantine document and you so now they
have to go into self coordinator for 14
days and if they fail to follow this
then there will be further enforcement
measures all right now of course by this
logic if just the simple if their simple
presence at a quote mass gathering means
that now their risk of contracting Cova
19 had to be put on unwarranted then
that would mean that every single person
who goes to Walmart or Target or to any
of the other quote-unquote essential
places also has possibly contracted it
and should be under a 14-day quarantine
right now you can tell me all you want
well those are essential well does the
fact that it's been arbitrarily decreed
essential by the government mean that
you're somehow at less of a is the virus
itself gonna take note of that and say
oh well the governor called
seneschal so we're gonna we're gonna lay
off here no if you're saying that simply
being around a lot of people puts you so
much at risk that you have to be put on
a 14 day quarantine then that should
apply to every single person who's been
in a mass gathering essential or not and
if it doesn't apply to both then what
you're really telling me that this is
not actually about safety it's about
something else now but I think we need
to clarify here this is not a quarantine
this is a house arrest to be clear he is
ordering men with guns to take down the
plates of people who go to church on
Easter and place them on house arrest
for 14 days
for the crime of being at church which
will simply be a stricter version of the
house arrest that we're all currently
under or at least if you're in you know
every state except for the seven same
ones now I know we've been using the
word quarantine I've been using it just
for the sake of simplicity
you know just calling it a quarantine
but that's actually a mistake we
shouldn't be calling it that I wish that
I had not been calling it that all along
this is not a quarantine and the
distinction is actually very important
here is Health and Human Services the
HHS website providing an official
government endorsed definition of what a
quarantine is this is what HHS says and
any where you look for a definition
you're gonna find basically something
similar to this
it says quarantine separates and
restricts the movement of people who
were exposed to a contagious disease to
see if they become sick these people may
have been exposed to a disease and do
not know it or they may have the disease
but not do not show any symptoms and
then isolation separate six sick people
with a contagious disease from people
who are not sick so quarantine is for
people who are known to have been or we
or who we have specific and very good
reason to think may have been exposed to
a contagion right that's what a
quarantine is but the government doesn't
know that anyone in that church has the
disease and thus has no specific reason
to think that anyone in the church has
been exposed to the disease so this is
not a quarantine Kentucky
as of this morning has fewer than 2,000
cases and fewer than 100 deaths in a
population of 4.4 million and spread out
over a you know relatively large state
with with not a very high population
density there is no specific reason to
assume that people at a church
automatically have been exposed to a
virus given the fact that there are only
2,000 confirmed cases or fewer than
2,000 now you might say that the virus
could have been much wider spread than
we're aware so that there are
exponentially more than 2,000 who
actually have the virus or had the virus
at some point that might be okay but the
problem is for the government anyway the
problem is that the only way to make the
case that anyone who attends any mass
gathering or goes to a church it can
automatically be reasonably suspected of
being exposed to the virus the only way
to make that case is to say that
probably you know it's not just 2,000
cases but there are hundreds of
thousands of cases or millions of cases
there have to be so many cases then you
have a high probability of being exposed
to it if you're simply around a bunch of
other people but if that's the case then
that would mean that the death rate is
much much much much lower than what
they're telling us that makes the death
rate exponentially lower than than what
they're currently saying and if that's
the case then that means that there's no
reason for the quarantine in the first
place that would mean that the disease
is not actually much deadlier than the
flu or or even you know maybe as deadly
as the flu in which case there's no
reason to respond to it this way now I
don't know if that's sure not but here's
my point either way you know either the
disease is much more widely spread than
the numbers show or it's not but either
way you can't call this a quarantine
it's house arrest you see the in either
case the logic doesn't work so we are
all we are all under a version of house
arrest as I said this is an important
distinction because those who defend the
shutdown's have argued that state
governments have a lot of latitude when
it comes to
putting people under quarantine people
under isolation and that's true they do
but that's not what this is in this case
they are shutting millions of businesses
down closing churches suspending the
right to religious liberty suspending
the right to assembly suspending our
fourth fourth amendment rights basically
suspending the entire Bill of Rights
locking people in their homes etc and
doing this to healthy people who we have
no reason to think have been exposed to
anything and in many cases states the
states where this is being done there is
no coronavirus emergency and never has
been in many of these states hospitals
are not only not overflowing but in fact
are so empty that health care workers
are being laid off so what is happening
is that the government is seizing near
total control based on projections and
that makes it very different from other
that people would argue you know similar
things have been done like in this with
the Spanish flu 100 years ago
we're told that well there were some
places that went into lockdown yeah but
that was not nearly as widespread and in
those cases that that was that was you
know places where there was an actual
present emergency with this virus that's
not what's happening here in most states
in most states they are not simply
isolating the sick and quarantine eing
the exposed which I absolutely think is
the right thing to do now that I'm
totally in favor of but they're not
doing that they are based on projections
shutting society down by force
preemptively because of something bad
that might happen possibly in the future
this raises a whole bunch of questions
the first one being what exactly are the
limitations on the government's newfound
right to preemptively shut down society
and lock healthy people in their homes
indefinitely based on the predictions of
the scientists on its own payroll
because even if you support what the
government is doing you must at least
acknowledge that the potential for abuse
which is being set by this is absolutely
enormous you must
at least admit that it's not hard to
imagine situations where the government
would would erroneously declare you know
that hey most of you currently aren't in
any serious danger but we have projected
that because of XYZ threat you might be
in the future at some indeterminate
point and so we are gonna go ahead and
and and curtail your civil liberties now
just in case and then proceed to
drastically you know do just that now
it's not hard to imagine scenarios where
they would do that on a faulty basis
even if you don't think this is a faulty
basis even if you think that the
predictions and the projections are good
in this case you must admit that giving
the government the power to do this
based on projections whether good or bad
does mean that we are now susceptible to
this kind of abuse of power in the
future and the thing is isn't that
reason enough to oppose it whatever you
think of the corona virus and its
relative threat to society shouldn't we
as Americans be skeptical of Authority
you know a jealous of our liberties and
therefore be opposed to the government
having this kind of power under any
circumstance I mean it's something to
think about at least and and most of the
people that are still supporting the
shutdown's from what I've seen they're
just not grappling with this in anything
close to a sufficient manner they're
putting blind faith in government and I
think we've learned throughout history
that you simply cannot do that okay
let's go to headlines but before we do
quarantine you know might not be any fun
well not Corinth I just said it's not
going to house-arrest may not be any fun
but you know it is fun The Daily wire
deal I'm about to share with you when
you become a daily wire insider plus or
all-access member then you'll not you'll
get not one but two of the highly
coveted leftist tears tumblr you get two
of them rumor has it that this tumblr
tumblr completely eliminates the threats
of immediate thirst that's how amazing
it is at least though we can't make any
other promises but at least if you put
that that's that's the one thing I can't
promise if you put a beverage in it and
you drink it
you will be less thirsty after drinking
you than you were before
unless it's like soda or something which
actually dehydrates you more so you know
even that even that promise we can't
totally fulfill but forget about that
daily wire members get many amazing
benefits including of course the leftist
ears tumblr but you get a lot more than
that you also get an ad for your website
experience access to our live broadcasts
and show library the full three hours of
the Ben Shapiro show daily wire members
get to ask us questions during backstage
and our new all-access live shows that
allow you to participate in these kind
of casual Q&A is that a lot of fun again
that's to to count'em leftist ears
tumblers not just one case you didn't
know what to means when you become a
daily wire member insider plus or
all-access member alright so number one
headlines this really should go into my
daily cancellation but I have an even
more urgent matter I have to address
there so we're gonna put it here instead
the New York Times published this past
weekend perhaps well it may just be one
of the most shameless pieces of faux
reporting we have yet seen from them and
that is saying quite a lot The Times did
a quote deep dive investigation into the
allegations by the by terror read
against Joe Biden she says that the
then-senator in 1993 sexually assaulted
her the upshot is that the times as you
can imagine found no reason to believe
the allegations and all but exonerated
Joe Biden or attempted to it anyway at
any rate now remember the New York Times
when it when it came to Brett Kavanaugh
found no allegation that it would not
believe but in this case it says with
these allegations we there's there's
there's you know very little credibility
here The Times report includes a really
amazing paragraph now this is actually
from a tweet thread that it posted along
with the article but the claim is
repeated in the article itself and
though that though it has been since
deleted from the article and from
Twitter but it said no other allegation
of sexual assault surfaced in the course
of our reporting nor did any former
Biden staffer corroborate Reid's
allegation listen to this we found no
pattern of sexual misconduct by Biden
beyond hugs kisses and touching that
women previously said
made them uncomfortable in other words
we found no pattern of sexual misconduct
except for the pattern of sexual
misconduct except for the pattern of
sexual misconduct there's no pattern of
sexual misconduct which makes a lot of
sense right that's like if a lawyer of a
serial killer for a serial killer in
court were to say Your Honor my client
resents the claim that he's a serial
killer
he has no pattern of murdering anybody
except for the 46 people buried in his
backyard except for them there's no
pattern here this is erroneous but of
course the times is not alone here the
media and the left in general seems to
have decided that the creepy old man who
regularly gropes women in public could
not possibly be guilty of sexual assault
and these are the same people who
decided that Brett Kavanaugh was
definitely the ringleader of a roving
band of gang rapists because one person
said that he was now I'm not saying that
Biden is guilty I think there are plenty
of good reasons to doubt the allegations
and I think just in general
my first instinct as I think it should
be for anybody is skepticism when you
have allegations without much evidence
with this kind of timing that come up in
a political campaign or with Brett
Kavanaugh you know right before you
confirm to the supreme court when that
doesn't mean they're not true
but you you with the timing you can
imagine other motivations a person might
have to make up a story or to embellish
or misremember it perhaps willfully so I
I don't know if it's true or not I'm
kind of agnostic about it when it comes
to to Joe Biden but here's what I do
know there is no basis at all to
disbelieve Tara Reid while believing
Christine Ford now you could be
skeptical of both or if you really are
in the believe all women camp you could
believe both which I think would be it
would be silly but but that would at
least be consistent and and you could
make a case as I'll explain in a minute
you could make a case for leaning
towards believing Tara Reid while not
believing Christine fort there is no way
for an honest person to make the
opposite case because think about Tara
Reid here are the things in her favor or
in in favor of her allegations being
true Terrie she told people about the
alleged assault when it happened and
they corroborate it there's at least two
people who said they heard about this
way before she came forward to the to
the media you know during the political
campaign so that's that's something
other aspects of the story have been
corroborated by witnesses you know
tangential sort of aspects that she
talks about she remembers every detail
so that's three things and she's
accusing a man with a known and recent
history of inappropriate physical
behavior to women and this is behavior
that we have seen for ourselves so we
know for a fact that it occurred that's
four things
christine ford on the other hand told
nobody about it no aspect of her story
was corroborated by anybody remembered
almost nothing about what happened and
was accusing a man with no established
or recent history of inappropriate
behavior to women so given those two
things if you find yourself saying yeah
but I still believe Christine Ford well
then you're just a partisan hack that's
all there is to it number two and social
media the social media site tick-tock in
particular has recently been overrun by
videos kind of like this one watch and
this one
nice little conga line there and then
also there's a nice little cupid shuffle
that some of the other nurses we're
doing watch this and then this one's
probably my favorite right here so this
is a new trend where nurses and hospital
staff are recording choreographed dance
videos at the hospital and posting them
online and the media has been swooning
over it you know saying it's
inspirational and motivating and
whatever now I've got myself into a lot
of trouble on Twitter because I tweeted
a criticism of this not call me crazy a
lot of people have over this and just in
general but I don't think hospital staff
should be taking time out to
choreographed dance routines at the
hospital and post them online you know I
would say that that's actually wildly
insanely inappropriate and I would say
that even in normal times okay if I had
a loved one that was at the hospital
dying and the nurse was was was it was
you know off choreographing a dance
routine on the clock at the hospital I'd
be upset about that I would be it seems
reasonable to be upset about that but
especially they shouldn't be doing it
now because we have been told that we
needed to shut down the whole economy
and embrace a Great Depression because
hospitals are being overwhelmed that's
what we were told all right
and now while millions of Americans wait
in line and edit food banks because
their jobs have been taken from them
because of the overrun hospitals while
that's happening we have hospital staff
posting dance videos okay I think a lot
of people are gonna look at that and say
why
why did I lose my job you're telling me
my business was destroyed and for this
they got nothing to do and they're
recording dance videos okay then why
can't I get back to work then isn't that
it that's it that's a good question
isn't it because there are two
possibilities here when you see these
videos either
these are hospital staff that have
nothing to do and so are just dancing
and recording it okay in which case
let's get back to work
or these are happening at hospitals
where there are people dying in a
pandemic and you've got nurses dancing
down the hallway literally dancing down
the hallway and recording and in posting
online I mean either way and I think
it's kind of a mixture too I mean some
of these videos are at the coronavirus
hospitals and some are at hospitals
where they got nothing better to do
either way in both cases I would say
wildly insanely inappropriate and I
can't believe that so many people are
defending it I mean I I don't know I
keep saying I can't believe when people
have stupid positions on things but
maybe I should start believing it
because it's pretty common listen I the
the argument I've heard in response to
my criticism and not just my criticism
here lots of people I've gotten a lot of
emails and messages from people who work
at hospitals anonymously telling me and
saying hey I don't want you to put this
out there publicly with my name attached
to it but I totally agree with you I
work at a hospital and this is crazy I
mean we would we would never do this in
my hospital right so I'm certainly not
the only one critical of it but the
argument I've heard is that well I've
got two things one I've been told that
I'm I shouldn't be against people having
fun you know I'm coming out against joy
and fun no it's it's to say that nurses
shouldn't be recording choreographed
dance routines and posting them online
in a hospital during a pandemic and a
shutdown that's cost 17 million people
their jobs in three weeks
that is not the same thing as saying
nobody should ever have fun okay doesn't
there's a lot of room in between nobody
have fun and nurses please don't
choreographed dance routines to post
them online during a pandemic I feel
like there's a lot of room in between
right and then the other thing is well I
don't understand that people that I have
these high-stress jobs they there's a
lot of gallows humor and and you know
they sometimes they joke around and have
fun just as a way of lightening the
environment I I get that okay but you
don't need to post it online
and it doesn't need to be choreographed
either I would think but but but even
you why do you need to post it online
okay why does it need to go it's like if
I let's say I did have a loved one that
was dying in the hospital now I'm under
no illusion that the nurses who are
tending to my dying loved one that
they're in a state of mourning and you
know are living the rest of their lives
somber and going home and crying about
it I'm sure they're not okay probably
they're in dealing with my dying loved
one and then they go to the next room
and they could be smiling and joking
around for all I know that's fine but
obviously yes I understand they're doing
that but they're not gonna walk into the
room with me when I'm sitting there with
my dying loved one and say how much I
was just having a great laugh in the
next room let me tell you this joke that
I heard no that would be extremely
inappropriate not because I'm saying
they shouldn't be joking around but keep
that to yourself okay have some decorum
and some class you keep it to yourself
you don't bring it into the room with
the dying people clearly but no I'm just
I'm a big Scrooge of course that's the
main thing which I am a Scrooge but I
don't think that has anything to do with
this number three the Philadelphia
Transit Authority last week issued
guidelines apparently asking people in
the city who use public transportation
to put on a mask and a few days later
when some people tried to get on a bus
without a mask they were informed that
they had to get off and they couldn't
ride and here's here's how that that one
watch this
[Music]
attention sir sir you have to get off
the bus you have to get off the bus sir
[Music]
sir now notice how that guy who's
screaming in an enclosed environment
spreading his spittle all around he's
not wearing a mask himself a guy without
a mask is screaming at people for not
having masks which is just great and
then one of the people on the bus didn't
have a mask and wasn't able to just
produce one out of thin air and so then
this happened
ILD incomes
so it seems like it'd be easier maybe
just give the guy a mask or a bandana or
something to wear around his face
instead officers dragged him off the bus
by his feet violating social distancing
in order to enforce social distancing
which seems like a rather foolish
strategy or you see a guy who's
supposedly violate social discing so you
get in his face and you start wrestling
him like maybe that's not the best way
to approach this I don't know but then
again I'm the guy who thinks that nurses
shouldn't be doing choreographed dance
routines at hospitals during a pandemic
so what do I know right because if any
look if anything was spread on that bus
it was spread either when the guy
without a mask was shouting or when they
were wrestling the guy with the other
guy without a mask like those would be
the two occasions where there was really
a risk of a virus being spread and that
is when they were making an attempt to
enforce these policies to prevent the
spread of the virus so that just doesn't
make a lot of sense and it gets even
dumber in fact because after the outcry
from this video the Transit Authority
announced that they're no longer going
to enforce the policy so they said oh
you know nevermind we're not gonna
enforce the policy anymore well hold on
a second okay either the policy is
necessary for Public Health or it isn't
if you're just gonna get rid of the
policy because people were upset then
doesn't that prove that the policy had
no reason to exist in the first place or
how about this just just this is why
government agencies are so stupid they
they're not capable the people in
government are not capable of thinking
with any nuance or actually thinking
through a problem because rat it's
actually not a bad idea to encourage
people to have a mask when they ride on
public transportation but you know there
is rather than trying to enforce the law
by dragging people off the bus by their
feet and then and then going to the
other extreme and saying never mind
we're not gonna have that policy how
about just think of better ways of
enforcing it you don't have to get rid
of the policy just think of a better way
of enforcing it like for example if
somebody doesn't have a mask then you
give them one or I mean even something
as simple as hey like put your shirt
over your nose or something something
like that now it's not as good as a
medical mass
but it's a lot better than nothing and
so even how about that instead but again
what do I know
alright that was three headlines but I
think we'll keep it at three I was what
those were three uh longer ones and
finally the last thing I need to do
before we wrap up for the show we get to
our daily cancellation this it may seem
a little bit like out of left field here
but I I will have to cancel today some
chickens some actual chickens I mean
chicks actually that's what they call
baby chickens in the farming world just
a little bit of technical terminology
for you so my wife went out this weekend
and bought some chicks and she had been
threatening to do this for a while and
then she went out and she was supposed
to be gone to the store of something and
in it somehow I think she went to
Walmart and on the way home she found
some chicks but I never really found out
how exactly and she came home with them
because she apparently has dreams of
being a chicken farmer and Who am I to
stand in the way of my wife's dreams but
unfortunately after only one day of
having the chicks I have to cancel them
and I'm gonna show you why this is
pretty disturbing stuff okay I I went to
check on them before bed the other night
and only because my wife asked me to so
I usually check on my kids before
bedtime but now I got to check on the
chickens too I don't really know what
I'm checking on the chickens for exactly
or like what what am I looking for
and even if I discover something amiss
what am I supposed to do about it like I
might if I find that a chicken is dying
what you want me to do am I supposed to
perform mouth-to-mouth CPR I don't know
but I went to check on the chickens and
dutifully you know as a good husband
didn't what I discovered is pretty
terrifying take a look at this picture
here and there under there under a heat
lamp so the color you know it so that's
why there's the reddish tint to it but I
think the reddish tint works because it
gives it a sort of satanic vibe and
these are satanic chickens you see here
this is how they grouped themselves the
dark colored chickens are huddled
together while the light colored
chickens are huddled in a different
group they have segregated themselves by
color my why
brought racist chickens into the house
which personally I should cancel my wife
too because how do you not ask this
question when you're at the farm or
wherever buying your chickens you didn't
think to ask them are these chickens
racist you didn't think to say can I get
the non racist chickens this is worse
than the time that my wife came home
with a transphobic kitten's once this is
even worse than that now I have tried my
hardest as you can imagine to instill an
appreciation for cultural diversity and
racial tolerance in my household it is
my number-one priority as a father and a
husband it's the main thing I'm
concerned about and so imagine my shock
when I look and I see racism and
Prejudice among the poultry in my house
and yes they are in my house right now
those chickens are in my house
physically because I've been told we
can't put them outside it's too cold for
them I mean they're animals you know I
think they go outside but what do I know
so of course I forcibly desegregated and
integrated them and you know I'm sitting
there for like 20 minutes trying to get
them trying to desegregate I'm
initiating a desegregation policy and
they keep going back clumping together
by color so anyway I killed them all and
turn them into chicken nuggets so that's
the end of that story
all right let's leave it there on a
happy note and again a Happy Easter once
more have a great day
be safe god bless Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
our supervising producers are Mathis
Glover and Robert Sterling our technical
producer is Austin Stevens edited by
Dani D'Amico and our audio is mixed by
Robyn Fenderson
the Matt Walsh show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20
hey everybody its Andrew Clavin host of
the Andrew Clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
American Republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching and the moon has
turned to blood but on the Andrew Clavin
show that's where the fun just gets
started so come on over to the Andrew
Clavin show and laugh your way through
the apocalypse with me Andrew Clavin
[Music]